hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start warning spoilers ahead have you
ever wondered if in the future mankind
will need to consume and digest trash in
order to survive
in the future humankind has experienced
numerous biological changes to be able
to adapt with the environment one of
them is Brecken a young boy who lives
happily with his mother on the seashore
from the physical appearance this boy
looks just like a normal human however
his digestive organs have altered
causing him to be able to consume
plastic and other inedible stuff seeing
this unusual behavior of her son the
mother becomes worried but cannot do
anything about it one night when Brecken
is asleep she sneaks into his room and
Smothers him with a pillow he tries to
resist but the mother keeps smothering
him until he's dead after that the
mother doesn't feel any remorse at all
because she thinks that the boy is not a
human being thus she never considers the
boy as her son she calls her husband to
confess and then leaves not long after
the father named Lang arrives at the
house to pick up the corpse
elsewhere a renowned performance artist
named Saul is laying helpless on an
advanced weird-shaped bed he suffers a
rare disease called accelerated
Evolution syndrome causing unusual
organs to constantly grow inside his
body because Saul's been in pain all
night due to the bed not functioning
properly his wife Caprice takes him to
another room to do a quick examination
she finds out that he's developing a
brand new organ inside his abdomen to
make things worse Saul is also born with
an unusual digestive system and has to
be fed by a chair to eat human food that
night the couple go to the National
Organ registry to consult about what's
happening to Saul's body upon arrival
they are welcomed by whippet and his
assistant Timlin whippet explains human
evolution has been concerning and might
lead the world into a dangerous place
this Evolution even causes Some Humans
unable to perceive physical pain anymore
because of that the government
established the organ registry to track
these biological changes Caprice who is
an ex-trauma surgeon tells the officials
that they are a performance artist
couple who regularly perform a live
surgery to remove Saul's new organ in
their shows inspired by the story
whippet and Timlin perform a quick
examination of Saul's new organ and
subsequently mark it with a registration
tattoo whippet also states that these
organs might be passed down to their
children and these children will no
longer be considered as humans in the
evening two technicians from the life
form where a company that produces
Advanced devices come over to their
house to recalibrate the bed they
perform some adjustment to the bed so
that it'll align with Saul's current
body's condition after that the couple
show them a very rare unlimited autopsy
unit that's not manufactured anymore the
technicians are very fascinated with the
machine it's the D-Day of the couple's
next show just after everyone's arrived
at the venue Caprice immediately
commences the surgery in front of the
audiences Saul's abdomen is cut open by
the autopsy unit controlled by his wife
revealing the new organ she then removes
the organ with the freshly Inked tattoo
on it meanwhile Lang observes the
performance from a distance a after the
show Timlin approaches Saul and Praises
him for the performance saying that the
surgery arouses her Caprice of course is
unhappy with the flirting and becomes
jealous on the other hand Lang
deliberately leaves a candy bar on the
table a man takes the bait and
immediately eats it shortly after he
dies due to food poisoning
the following day Timlin and whippet are
interrogated by detective cope he finds
out that the officials had a deal with
Saul and ask them about the organ's
removal performance shown by the couple
Timlin believes that what the couple's
doing is a new way of performing art
shows but cope doesn't think that a
tumorous growth inside a human body is
an art to convince the detective the
officials then show him the portfolio of
Saul's removed organs back to the couple
Caprice discovers that her husband's
developing a new organ again which
surprised her because the interval
between growths is closing up Saul is
very happy with it the couple later
attend another organ performance of a
fellow artist who his ears growing all
over his body there Saul meets with a
woman who recommends him to go to an
inner beauty specialist called Dr
nassateer outside the building Lang sea
Saul and decides to approach Him He
suggests Saul utilizes the autopsy unit
to perform a real autopsy on a real
corpse as part of a Show's he's even
willing to donate his son's body for the
performance claiming that there would be
surprises inside the body thinking that
the father is crazy he leaves him
without giving any response at home Saul
tells his wife about the corpse autopsy
show idea Caprice agrees to it but she
thinks that they have to apply some
modification into the machine the wife
lays naked inside the machine and they
begin to check the machine later that
night Saul secretly rendezvous with
Detective cope turns out that all this
time he's been working for the detective
in an undercover Mission Saul tells him
about his meeting with the woman earlier
and Coke orders him to follow it up in
exchange of the information Saul
requests to talk with brecken's Mother
afterwards Saul goes to drive NASA tears
place where the doctor proposes to
install a zipper to his abdomen he also
invites Saul to take part in an inner
beauty pageant where everyone can freely
show off their Neo organs as Saul
arrives home he shows his newly
installed zipper to his wife Caprice is
not quite surprised then the couple have
an intimate moment together in the
morning Saul meets with brecken's Mother
inside a prison until now she still
considers her deceased son as a creature
future because of his unusual digestive
organs and she blames the father Lang
for that moving to Lang's perspective it
turns out that he's the one who runs a
poisonous candy bar factory he and all
his men have their digestive system
modified so that they can consume and
digest plastic wastes it's also revealed
that the candy bar is made of toxic
waste that's why people with a normal
digestive system will die upon consuming
it meanwhile capris attends another
human modification show this time the
artist named odile deliberately create
scars on his own face and surprisingly
the performance is covered by many
journalists Caprice is intrigued by the
art behind the self-herting or they call
it a desire to be open so deal invites
her to join the after party event that
night she shows all her new scar
modification on her forehead the husband
is surprised but does not comment any
further about it Caprice insists that
she wants to perform the corpse autopsy
herself they argue but then Saul agrees
to it Saul visits the National Organ
registry where whippet reveals that he's
the Registrar of inner beauty pageant he
thinks that Saul has a good chance of
winning the legal event shortly after
Saul is approached by Timlin inside a
secret room Saul asks her whether she
has ever encountered a system of
neo-organs that have a fully functional
digestive system allowing the human to
be able to digest Plastics she claims
that until now she's only discovered
single organ growths like Sauls not the
whole system
moments later the couple rendezvous with
Lang in his place where he shows them
their object of show which is his own
son's body upon seeing the body Caprice
suddenly changes her mind and wants to
withdraw the autopsy show Lang attempts
to convince the couple saying that he
needs to make a strong public statement
towards the government who is against
the evolutionist group Lang argues that
breckins Langs and Saul's modified
digestive system is a natural process
that should not be hindered because
that's the consequences of environmental
damage caused by humans and Industrial
wastes Saul later consults with
Detective cope to decide whether he
should proceed with the show or not cope
states that he should continue because
he wants to use this opportunity to get
rid of Lang and all humans that can eat
Plastics waste he argues that they are
evolving away from Human path therefore
must be banished the next day the
technicians from the life form were
knock on Dr nassateer's door instead of
repairing the chair it turns out that
they come there to assassinate the
doctor
the couple pay a visit to Lang's Factory
this time Lang explains that he and the
others deliberately modified their
digestive system because he thinks it's
time for humans to start feeding on
their own Industrial Waste he also
reveals that Brecken was the very first
human to be born with a plastic
processing digestive system meaning that
Lang's modified digestive system passed
down to his offsprings Lang believes
that Brecken was a symbol of Hope but
since he's killed by his own mother
there's no other way than a public
autopsy to reveal this miracle to the
world after a long discussion the show
eventually begins Caprice is the main
star on the show while Saul operates the
autopsy unit backstage unfortunately
when they cut open the abdomen the
audiences find nothing special about
becken's digestive organs except they
are rotten and tattoo scrawled on them
everyone especially Lang is very
disappointed with the result while
Caprice keeps trying to catch the
audience's attention with dramatic
statements Lang then goes out of the
venue and cries suddenly the technicians
approach him and eliminate him after the
show all meets with cope again and
demands him to tell the truth it turns
out that cope ordered Timlin to remove
becken's original organs and replaced it
with normal organs he thinks that it's a
necessary action in order to prevent the
news from spreading worldwide feeling
betrayed Saul leaves him in Anger since
then Saul refuses to sleep on the
advanced bed and struggles to eat in the
chair Caprice then decides to give him
the candy bar as soon as Saul takes the
first bite the pain suddenly goes away
and he cries with happiness
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching